this colorful cylinder is a piece of
mouse brain a very small piece it's two
hundredths of a millimeter long it may
be small but it's a really complete
infantry
unlike previous efforts to map the brain
it contains all the cell types in this
area not just the neurons and it's from
the cortex an area that does more
sophisticated computations here's the
area next to a human hair even this
micro sample is giving surprising hints
about how the brain works to do the
study a Harvard team used a machine to
cut a piece of mouse cortex into
thousands of wafer thin slices which
they stuck on a ribbon and scanned
here we're moving through the stack of
brain slices like a flipbook the team
took these still images and crunch the
data to rebuild the piece of brain
tissue it's from a bit of the mouse
brain that receives information from the
skin here are all the neurons which
feature in some way in the spec of brain
the team focused on but they were really
only able to analyze this much they
focused on two brain cell branches that
interact in this portion you can start
to make out the components here in red
and green the two main cell branches
then all the other neurons that travel
through the area at some point here are
all the sign APS's the connections that
neurons make with each other here are
the inhibitory connections which dampen
down activity and not forgetting the
non-neuronal cells like these glir which
support the neurons and help them send
messages to each other all in an area
smaller than a dust mite this tiny
tissue sample is teaching scientists and
principles of brain mechanics
neuroscientists often assumed that
neurons that are neighbors are likely to
connect more than distant ones but the
team was surprised to find that this
pattern didn't hold in this image all
the neuron branches are very closely
packed but only the red and yellow here
in the middle are actually connected
humans have a much bigger cortex than
mice and it's where all the interesting
stuff happens like our memory and
personality but given how much data
lives in this tiny piece of mouse brain
doing the same for humans is a distant
prospect then again nobody said the
brain was going to be easy to understand
did they
you